الان لا تداعيات زلزال كهرمان مرعش حيث
ارتفعت حصيله القتلى في تركيا الى اكثر من
خمسين الفا ومع استمرار الهزات الارتداديه
قالت السلطات التركيه انها نقلت نصف مليون
مواطن الى مناطق اكثر امنا انضم الينا من
غازي عنتاب مراسل الجزيره عمر الحاج اهلا
بك معنا كثير من الملفات بيد السلطات
التركيه على راسها ربما موضوع الايواء
صحيح عبد السلام موضوع الايواء وايضا
موضوع الهزات الارتداديه التي
تجاوز عددها 9000 هزه خلال الايام الماضيه
لعل اخرها وقعت قبل نحو قبل نحو ساعتين من
الان في منطقه جديده هذه المره بعيده عن
منطقه البحر الابيض المتوسط في
حدث فيها زلزال كبير 6.4 فيها او حتى
زلزالين الاخرين الذين وقع في ملاطيا
ومرعشنا نتحدث عن منطقه وسط الاناضول في
محافظه في ولايه نيدا حيث سجلت هزه بشده
5.2 على مقياس ريختر لم تتحدث السلطات عن
اي اضرار ناجمه عن هذه الهزه ولكن كما
ذكرت البعد الجديد في المساله انها تحدث
في مناطق مختلفه عن الصفائح الجنوبيه التي
حدثت فيها الزلازل الماضيه ايضا كما ذكرت
موضوع الاجلاء والسلطات تتحدث عن اجلاء
الايواء والاجلاء اجلائي 400,000 وايضا
ايواء مئات الالاف من العائلات التي تضررت
بيوتها بشكل كبير والحديث عن مسابقه الزمن
في مسعى لصنع البيوت المسبقه الصنع سواء
هذا المصنع الجديد الذي دخل للعمل في
ولايه ملاطيا او المصانع الاخرى التي
تحاول السلطات مده العوائل التي فقدت
بيوتها بيوتها كما ذكرت في مناطق الزلازل
ايضا السلطات الان امام تحدي جديد لان فرق
التقييم لا تبحث فقط في المناطق التي
اتضررت في البيوت التي تضررت بل انها تبحث
في الابنيه قيد الانشاء اذ ان وزير
الداخليه في حديث سابق له قال ان هناك
حمله على المشاريع قيد الانشاء التي على
وشك الانتهاء منها اثبتت ان الكثير من هذه
البيوت وهذه المشاريع السكنيه وجد انها
غير صالحه للسكن وانها تضررت بالزلزالين
وان هناك حمله اخرى اما لهدمها او اصلاحها
وتدعيمها في سبيل ايواء المتضررين من
الزلازل شكرا جزيلا لك من غازي عنتاب
مراسل جزيره عمر الحاج على كل هذه
الاضاحات